in this video we're going to walk through
everything you need to know to set Ninja
Trader up properly and have it effectively work
for you and not be frustrating We're going to go
through what data to select how to set up charts
exactly how you want every little trick and tool
that you need to know I've used Ninja Trader for
over 5 years now and as well we're going to go
through how to set an ATM strategy up This is a
massive thing when it comes to trading in Ninja
Trader and you will really want to know how to
set that up properly so you can effectively enter
and exit trades If you want to skip to something
specific make sure to just go through the chapters
at the bottom of the video Now first off if you've
never used Ninja Trader before it's an extremely
powerful trading platform I'll leave a link for
you to get started with it below Now first off
when you are selecting what kind of trading data
to get from Ninja Trader every trading platform
you generally have to acquire specific data Now
on the Ninja Trader website what you're going
to want to do is you're going to want to go to
the top right and go to settings And then from
there you'll go to plans And what this will do is
you're probably not going to see I currently have
something already going here but you'll want to
see this where you can either update subscription
or you'll just see select some kind of market
data subscription Now the two main options they
give you is you can either do you know level
one data or level two data Now level two data
is really expensive if you don't actually need
that kind of information And what you can do is
this level one data for $12 a month will give you
every market out there You can click here to view
products or what you can do is you can go down to
customize and you can say and go through each one
of these and say which ones you want They have
some crazy you know I don't even know what kind
of futures data this is at $140 a month But what
you can do is if you don't want to pay that $12
a month and you say "Hey I just want to trade
you know the ES futures and the NASDAQ futures
you don't even need to get that $12 a month you
can just select that specifically by going with
just the CME." And if you're ever unsure of what
these each have you can just click view products
and it will tell you exactly what's in here You
can see the NASDAQ futures are in here and also
the ES futures and a lot of other markets And
so that's a really easy way to get cheap data
without having to pay a ton per month which is
pretty standard across every trading platform Now
when you first open up the Ninja Trader desktop
platform what you're going to do is you're going
to just get a window like this There's going
to be no charts or anything and you're going
to have to connect to your data stream first And
so what you have to do is you have to go up here
to connections And then you can see I have a
couple ones here that are set up already But
what you're going to have to do is click configure
down here And then there's going to be a ton of
different available feeds here And so that's
what you can do is with Ninja Trader Trading
Platform is you can connect to a ton of different
platforms if you don't actually specifically want
to use Ninja Trader as your brokerage And so when
you start using Ninja Trader they're going to send
you an email with information of how to connect
and which one of these to use to connect your
data And then you're going to have to just have
a username and a password And then what you can
do is just click connect automatically connect
on startup because then every time you open up
you won't have to go up here and say "Okay I want
to connect to the system." And then you can see
these green buttons or down here This will light
up as green when you're connected and you should
see data and your charts once you have them up
will start to update If it's yellow or red or
gray you're having issues connecting Now you won't
necessarily have a ton of different accounts here
but what you can do is you can click add simulated
account and you can just set them up and make more
if you want Now one thing on Ninja Trader is the
trading platform doesn't necessarily reflect your
commissions and so you need to add what you have
most likely you have the free version and so and
then you can also just create initial capital and
and set up essentially a simulated account and
then you know you'll click okay and it will make
an account for you Now to get into charts and how
to set up a chart what you're going to do is at
the top here you're going to go to new and you'll
go down here to chart and what it's going to do
is it's going to bring up this data series This
is essentially you saying okay what do I want
to trade you're going to go to instrument And
now this up here is basically a quick look back
at what you previously have been doing But most
likely you won't have that if you're starting a
fresh system And so for me you know okay I want
to look at futures I'm going to go to futures here
And I'm going to just pull up the NASDAQ futures
And then from there it'll populate this area on
the right And what you can do is you can say okay
what type of chart do you want to do it on minute
second day You know you can change it to all the
different options you want You can go based on
volume range I like to use a minute chart You can
set it up to be a one minute chart And then you
can load data based on different things And so I
usually like to just load you know 15 days worth
of data for a one minute chart It just gives you
enough time to zoom back if you want And then from
there this stuff is pretty standard You can always
go back I'll tell you I'll show you how to go back
and find this Just click okay I'm just going to
double click to make it full screen And the first
thing to get those settings back you'll see now a
ton of buttons here at the top This button right
here it's called data series It'll bring all those
settings back up So if you ever want to go in
here and change things you can now see you can
start to you know there's lines on the chart and
stuff You can start to change those You can also
come in here and actually change the colors of
your candlestick bars if you you know feel so
inclined to do that I actually normally use white
and blue for my candlesticks I don't actually like
trading red and green candlesticks just cuz they
uh you know kind of trigger uh anxiety or emotions
a lot easier Now some super quick basic things is
you can leftclick to you know drag and move the
chart around but generally it's kind of locked And
what you can do then is hold control I'm holding
the left control button and I can move it around
a lot more freely Now you can see I can move it
all the way here I can go off the screen Now if
you're off the screen and you want to snap the
chart back there's just this little F button up
here at the top right corner and it'll snap you
back And then this arrow here will also pop up
if your chart isn't matched to the right side
Now if you rightclick on the chart and go down to
properties this brings up other settings that you
can do Now first off a big key one is right side
margin I usually have this at something like 200
And it just that the right side margin is just
this area right here Basically it essentially
just is you know how much extra space do you want
there you know I kind of like having it a little
bit extra space It helps me visualize things a
bit more Um and then kind of some big things is
you can turn on or off horizontal grid lines or
you can just make them thicker you know and most
of these settings are pretty self-explanatory but
that's how to do a lot of that stuff Now if you
ever want to kind of save a preset you see down
here you can click preset and you click save And
so it'll save that kind of as your default chart
setup Now you can always just click and drag on
the X or Y-axis of the chart too That's another
easy quick way to move the chart around Now if you
want to add indicators to your chart you can click
this indicator button up here And you can see
there's a ton of default indicators you can add
or there are custom indicators These are custom
indicators I've built for the platform It just
comes in a nice little folder I can add this one
And you can just click you know it'll always have
all the settings right here And you can always
click pretty much for anything any drawing tools
any indicators This template down here you can
always click and then click save as default And
then that'll always be the default that's there
or you can save it as another option And you can
just click okay and that indicator will show up
And all that indicator is is just a little timer
right here just to show you a countdown timer of
where the bar is going to close And so that I find
that super helpful to have especially trading on
a one or five minute chart For something a little
bigger it's not as necessary Now another important
setting is I can click on the right side axis here
and go to properties Now this brings up properties
that are important to use as well So one thing I
like to do is I like to have fixed horizontal grid
lines versus automatic And so what this does
you can see it didn't do anything because I
technically have if I go back to properties here I
technically have horizontal grid lines off And so
what I'm going to do is I'm just going to reshow
these I kind of like actually having grid lines on
most of the time It makes things a little easier
But so what you can do here is you can have it
as fixed grid lines versus automatic automatic
kind of just make it kind of look nice Now the
reason why I like fixed is because you can do it
based on ticks points or pips Now what I like to
do is I like to have it based on points And this
is because anytime you open a chart is you know
and just look at the candlesticks without an an
easy reference it's kind of hard to understand
the volatility of the market Now if I put in here
that I want a horizontal grid line every 10 points
Now this is on the NASDAQ It's going to show me
you know grid lines that kind of make sense You
know this is kind of today's chart And then if I
go back you know here you can see the grid lines
are a lot bigger showing you visually very easily
that the candlesticks are much smaller and there's
less volatility versus if I zoom back forwards
you can see they're very tight And so there's a
ton of volatility going on today And that is super
easy and really important for trading consistently
every day I think to be in tune with how the
market is moving Now the next big thing for
charts of course is drawing tools Now if you
right click on a chart you can bring up most
of the settings that are up here Pretty much you
can see there's data series alerts Another thing
here is if you want alerts you can set up alerts
for Ninja Trader You can say hey I want to add an
alert and the condition is if the NASDAQ you can
actually do this based on lines as well So you can
say if I draw a line here and I actually you can
rightclick the line and I can set an alert based
on that line and it will pretty much automatically
set it up for you and I can say okay I want to
alert if the price crosses below that line You can
you know go in here and change it exactly how you
want But that's something super helpful if you are
you know not actively trading You're you know I I
want to see this and you know I want to come back
to the charts if it shows up here And so what this
will do is it'll send an alert to you if the price
crosses this line Now to go back to this there's a
couple of other settings here You know you could
have crosshair I like to put local crosshair on
Just for me it kind of makes it a lot easier to
visualize especially if I'm looking to enter in
a trade It kind of allows me to easily visualize
where I am based on the actual x-axis And then
another thing too here is this is where you can
easily get to drawing tools I find it a little
easier to just rightclick and then pull up drawing
tools here And you can see there's you know a ton
of different drawing tools There's your classic
lines your pretty much your standard setup that
every platform has And so what you're going to do
is you know for me I like to use rectangles for
my support and resistance zones And so what your
rectangle is not going to look like this initially
And what you can do to bring up properties like
every other drawing tool you can rightclick or
just doubleclick it to bring up the properties
And then it'll bring up your properties And you
can say you know for for this you know I've have
the opacity really low You can change the colors
You can say "Okay I want it specifically on just
this chart." Or if I have multiple charts I want
to have it come up on all the charts And so
we'll go into multiple chart setup in a second
and I can show you that more But again down here
the template is I save this as default And so my
default is every time that I pull this up it's a
you know an exact setup of how I want And so same
thing with this the line any other drawing tool
I consistently use has some default setting that
I really like Again you can also get those up here
at the top left Now let's get into making multiple
charts Now so for multiple charts first off if
you go in the bottom left you'll see a little plus
sign down here This is if I want to make another
tab And so you can go in here and you know set
up okay I now want to you know let's use the micro
ES futures And I'll click okay because I think you
know my my kind of default is is works for me And
it will bring up the micro ES futures And you can
see I I have a bunch of saved charts or or drawing
tools on my chart because they you know it's saved
in my system from me actively trading this morning
That's one way to easily make a chart Or you can
rightclick on this and just say duplicate in new
tab or new window The nice thing about that is if
once you have all the chart settings exactly how
you want you can just easily duplicate another
one so you don't have to do it all over again
because that's kind of annoying And so just to
bring these two charts side by side now you can
see that these drawing tools are you know the
same on all charts But if I select one minute on
it it'll only be on this chart It won't globalize
it to all NASDAQ charts Now one cool thing to show
you is if you go to the top right here in each of
the charts you'll see two little red boxes Now
what you can do is this is how you can link the
charts via instruments And so what this does is I
don't know why but for some reason for me to get
to work I need to put both as red And so what this
will do though is if I change this chart to the ES
futures it'll change this chart as well Or if I
change it to oil futures it'll change both charts
And as well if you want to use something like a
superdom you can link this as well So if I go in
here and I change to a different chart you'll
see this changes to the ES futures as well So
that's a super nice way if you have you know some
specific setup you have and you just want to cycle
through things like that That's a super easy way
to do that Now when it comes to quickly drawing
I find it really important to have hotkeys And so
what you want to do is pull up your Ninja Trader
main window And if you go to tools you can go to
hotkeys And what you can do then is you can go to
it'll you can do chart market analyzer all these
other you know superdom But for drawing tools what
you can do is you'll just scroll down and your
main drawing tools you'll find here And you can
change them to different hotkeys I just use F you
know 1 2 3 4 and 5 above number 1 2 3 and four and
five just cuz I find that super easy to do and it
doesn't normally mess up a lot of other hotkeys
that there are Now one thing to save your charts
once you have them set up how you want you need to
go to workspace and then click save Now what you
need to do is if you want to make a new one just
click new here and it will totally start you fresh
and it will have a saved one that you can start
from scratch and go from there and just quickly to
you know open up you know kind of your main setup
You can easily do that by clicking you know that
last whatever you have it saved as Now if you ever
have any questions about specific things on Ninja
Trader all you have to do is click F1 and it will
open up a help window on the internet specifically
for that area that you're looking at and it will
give you a ton of helpful tips So if you ever you
know if there's something I didn't talk about in
this video which I'm sure there is you can easily
find that there Now now let's get into the chart
trader So if you go back up to chart settings
and options just click this chart trader button
and it'll bring up this side panel Now this is
really important for entering and exiting your
trades on the chart specifically If you want
to use the superdom you can totally use that
but personally I like to use entering in on the
chart Now if I right click above the chart it'll
give options for buy stop market orders or sell
limit orders And below it'll do the the flip side
So I can click and put in a buy limit order And
you can see here this is the order quantity that
it'll get put at So right there I have four
technically You can change that pretty easily
and you know just put in one contract if that's
what you're kind of looking to do Now a couple
important settings before we get into setting up
your ATM strategy is just right click on this and
you'll bring up properties Now you can change a
couple things in here You can change the colors
around you know kind of basic things You can show
P&L You can also change the length Now if I put in
another order here you can change the length that
this comes out And that is just basically by this
I can just double it to 50% in the screen I kind
of like to keep it 25 It keeps it on the side Uh
and then you can change the display units that So
if I just quickly click buy up here it'll fill me
in order And I can change this to you know display
percentage the technically the percentage isn't
your count it's the movement in that market And
then you know you can change it to ticks you can
change it to points Points I think is probably
the most standard Or you can just have none This
is actually what I commonly use on my charts is
just display none because at the end of the day
I don't want to you know think about the money
I just want to try and be making the logical
decision based on you know what the chart is doing
Now probably the most important setting of this is
your ATM strategy selection mode I like to do keep
selected because what it will do is it will select
your ATM strategy order every time you enter in a
new trade or contract So it'll allow you to keep
them selected and you know you can see here it'll
it'll separate them If you want to instead it
have it essentially select the active one to where
they're combined You can see here if I do it it'll
it'll add it as eight right here And so it'll
essentially be it'll combine them versus breaking
them up And you can see here it's only on one
specific one And so that's just you know kind of
an important thing to do with that Other than that
though you know it it's pretty self-explanatory
like most things Now let's get into setting up
your ATM strategy Now you'll need to click down
this drop-own menu Usually you'll have none
selected and you just need to click on custom
to bring up the parameters for setting one up Now
the basics of how this works is it'll have a order
quantity That's how many contracts or shares
whatever you want to are trading it's going to
default to be putting in And then you can select
based on the parameter type And so that is meaning
down here when this enters in I want to have it
have a stop loss of let's say 50 ticks Now I can
change this to you know points And so what that'll
do is if I just click okay based on that and I
click buy market this stop-loss is 50 ticks away
from my entry Now if I go back to that and edit
it again I can also add in a profit target of 50
ticks And if I click okay buy market essentially
it makes a bracket order And this would be
essentially a 1 one risk-to-reward ratio And
so now to get more complicated here what you can
do is you can click add and you'll you can create
a second target And so let's say I just want
my first target to be at one times my risk and
my second target to be at two times my risk And
so what you can do here is your quantity Then I
can you know I can have it be half and half right
if I'm going to enter four contracts I want two
contracts to be at 1x and two to be at 2x And then
you can see this it still keeps these together but
if I right click on it I can move them separately
And so the only way I've figured out to really do
that is click increase price and then we'll kind
of separate them And then you can easily kind of
separate them and then move them based on that So
like let's say I want to move one to break even
and I can And then what happens is you know when
this hits I don't know if it's you know to kind of
speed things you can see there it got hit and it
closed out the two limit orders here and the two
stop-loss orders there and I only have two left
And then you can you know continue to trade based
on those Now the other interesting thing is if I
let's say I am changing like I go in here and say
okay I'm going to trade eight contracts I have
that same custom parameter selected You can see
here this is broken up in two and two And so if
I click buy market you can see it breaks it up in
two and six And so how that works is essentially
if we go to if I close this back up you can see
the first target is taking most of them and the
second target is capping out at two And so this
is how if you quickly change that without changing
this because in real time it's kind of annoying to
go in here and change how you select this is you
can have this to be larger and then you know if I
trade four contracts it'll just fill the first one
but if I trade you know eight contracts it'll fill
them roughly you know half and half and I let's
say I do 10 it will you know do four and six and
so it's pretty hard to perfectly break things up
how you want Now one way to do this though is that
I I would say I generally do it is instead is you
know you just have one target If I just click here
to remove that other one and I click buy and
let's say I have 10 contracts And so what I
do to kind of deal with the issues of you know it
not always breaking things up properly what I'll
sometimes do is I will say okay well I'm going
to put in a limit order of you know six contracts
Now I'm going to change my order quantity and
just manually put in for six contracts And so
if I quickly drag this down to try and let it
get filled you'll see it filled there And boom
this order changed to having four and this order
changed to having four Once that order was hit
and closed out it essentially updated everything
else So you don't have to worry about you know
this essentially still being at 10 and this
still being at 10 and you know you potentially
accidentally getting more contracts than you mean
than you want to get Now of course what you want
to do with this is once you have it set up how you
want you want to click save as template And then
I suggest saving it as something that makes sense
You know how many ticks your stop loss is or how
many you know what the riskreward ratio is Now one
thing you can do too is if you have your profit
target as zero it will only put in a stop-loss
That's actually what I do most of the time And
then I will manually say okay rightclick you know
I have four contracts I want to take half off at
you know let's say I I would be targeting this
high up there because I think that's likely where
the market's going to reverse Now if it breaks
out you know this will change to two and I can
slowly trail things up right that's a little more
fluid way to play things out that I like to do But
again as you can see in here if you click on more
I didn't really talk about this There's a lot of
different things you can do to have things you
know trail up basically automatically You don't
have to do it manually Now I don't really like to
do an automatic trailing stop but there's ways in
here to essentially set that up to do that You
can basically make it so it'll you know have a
stop strategy right here If I click custom here
you can see it'll bring up an auto break even
It'll bring up a trailing stop It gets it can
get a lot more complicated than what I've just
shown you But for me personally I kind of like to
keep it simple because I'm you know managing based
on what I see on the chart Now one thing that I
think is really important when it comes to trading
on Ninja Trader and just trading in general is
knowing how much money you're risking per trade
Now in futures and you know when we discuss how
the candlesticks can widely range I don't think
it's smart to say oh I'm going to consistently be
entering in four contracts because you know four
contracts today in this market could be a huge
amount of risk that you're not normally used to
And so what I do and what I've actually built for
Ninja Trader is a riskreward tool It's called ET
riskreward You won't find this natively on your
platform you'll just see the normal riskreward
tool But what I've done is I've kind of adjusted
it to where essentially it'll allow me to have
like for me right now I have a target risk of
around $700 per trade And so you can see well if
I want to enter in here and put my stop loss let's
say above this little swing if I want to try and
get short well I need to trade seven contracts and
so I need to adjust this to seven contracts What
this does is it actually automatically adjusts
that cuz you can see if I want to then have you
know a larger stop-loss like if I entered up here
and I want to put my stop loss all the way above
this swing high well guess $700 of risk for that
big of a swing it's actually only four contracts
to essentially target around $700 And you can see
what's nice about this is it automatically updates
the order of quantity to you know based on this
adjustment So you can easily see okay where am I
you know how much am I risking how much do I need
a trade to hit that risk and then you can see it
also has just basic targets in here one times two
times three times your risk how much money that is
at this current risk and you can easily adjust
this if you know if I say hey I want to trade
$100 you know this market's kind of wide for $100
but you can see here okay I could still enter in
$100 here but it needs to be one contract and
so this is extremely important when it comes
to trading to pay attention to because otherwise
you're just going to blow your account because one
day you know the size is way smaller and you can
see you know maybe $100 is if I zoomed in cuz the
contracts are smaller $100 is four contracts but
today $100 is one contract And so that's really
important to pay attention to It's something I
highly recommend checking out if you are serious
about using Ninja Trader I'll leave a link to you
know how you can get this in the description below
And as well the other thing that I built for
Ninja Trader I have a lot of tools I built for
Ninja Trader you can check them out in a link to
below but one other really important one I think
that really improves trading on Ninja Trader is
you know you have to rightclick to click buy or
sell right and what this tool does is it allows
me to just hold a hotkey and click buy or sell And
so that's super valuable when the market's moving
quickly or if you just kind of want ease of access
And you can see it it adjusts These tools together
are really powerful because I can quickly say okay
I want to enter in here I want my stop loss here
And boom four contracts Or if you know because the
way this changes I can easily say oh now it's
six contracts And so those are super helpful
Now these are custom Ninja Trader indicators And
so they're a little tricky to install And so how
you install any custom Ninja Trader indicator
is you go to this main Ninja Trader tab window
again go to tools and go to import and then
you'll go to Ninja Trader Script add-on And
so what it'll do is it'll just bring up a folder
directory And what you need to do is you need to
then go and find you know wherever you put it in
your computer and where you put the third party
add-ons you're looking to install Now the
biggest issue I see with all of them is if
you have it located in your one drive You cannot
have Ninja Trader files of thirdparty indicators
located in your one drive They need to be stay as
a zip folder and then placed on your computer in
a local folder If you have it in a one drive the
arrow will often pop up like this And all you'll
see is just a bunch of directory But what you're
looking for is for it to say one drive If you see
one drive in that that means it's in a one drive
folder and you need to move it into a local file
Now just to show you the other really cool third
party custom indicator I've built is just a news
navigator I call it is essentially just you have
a big list here that shows you every news event
possible across all markets You can change it to
you know just be in the US And you can see here
on the on the chart as well it also will give you
vertical lines So when you're trading you can see
that okay there's a bunch of news coming out you
know kind of in the morning and then there's a
couple other news events in the afternoon and you
can see okay which news events are important and
what to stay away and be aware of because when
you're trading you know news is really important
to pay attention to You don't want to jump in a
trade have a news event come out and just you know
wipe out your trade all of a sudden So those
are really helpful to really I think unleash
the power of the platform I've used it again
you know for 5 years and over the time I built
these because I felt that they just improved the
platform and things that they didn't have in the
system natively And so I'll leave a link for all
those Ninja Trader indicators in the link in the
description below And if you want a more in-depth
explanation on futures trading because that's what
I mainly do on Ninja Trader check out this video
right here I go through every nuts and bolts
explaining the ins and outs of futures how they
work and how I trade them consistently every day